Hello everybody, hope that you are good.
It's happening. Bitcoin is finally doing
it, okay? We've been talking for the
past 2 weeks about the idea of a
deviation here, about the range high. It
happened after deviation, okay? Um or
confluence was all these long candles
here at the highs, okay? And then price
reversing very quickly to the downside.
Also, this high here
created a lot of liquidations and stop
losses in this zone between 31,700
and 31,800. Uh perfectly touched that
zone. So, I'm very happy for that. You
have the deviation, then if you go into
the lower time frame, okay? You can see
here how they consolidated, okay? On the
resistance, that's a short trigger. I
took my short from 31,400.
It's currently still running, although I
take I took some profits, okay? So, it
is not the full margin. Um then you had
the drop.
You go back to the range lows here. Uh
we've been talking this week about this,
okay? Bitcoin couldn't go higher for the
simple reason that the dollar index was
bouncing off. So, remember that Bitcoin
trades trades against the dollar. So,
when the dollar goes up, Bitcoin cannot
go up, okay? In the best case scenario,
it's going to hold or uh usually dumps,
okay? In this case, it was uh holding.
So, that was telling me
that Bitcoin didn't want to go down
straight away. So, there was likely to
see uh
short squeeze in the weekend.
Okay? Then yesterday, in the Sunday
update, I posted this prediction, okay?
That it was, you know, let me get the
4-hour 50 MA. It was a push over the
weekend, then come and retrace uh well,
and retest the 4-hour 50 MA as support.
Maybe another spike
to this zone, okay? Right above um
uh the mid-range of the deviation.
Could you have here these two
resistances, okay? And then, you know,
on Tuesday,
um I think in Tuesday tomorrow we're not
going to see much going on. I think
they're going to hold price and then
drop on Wednesday with the FOMC meeting
and a new hike of 25 basis points, okay?
But, that didn't really happen, okay?
Because instead, what they did was dump
from here. So, we're going to talk about
it now. We're going to try to make some
sense of this move, okay? But, as we
were anticipating, once they've taken
the liquidity at the highs,
I don't see much reason to go higher,
you know? What it makes more sense, you
know, if they're taking the liquidity
from one of the ends of the range,
usually they're going to go for the next
one, okay? For the next um
end of the range. And I mean, yes, we
can talk about possibility of um
deviation here and get back inside the
range, okay?
That could happen, but
we're going to look at the dollar index,
we're going to talk about the FOMC
meeting,
um also, when you're in a range and you
see a deviation in one of the ends of
the of the range,
you usually see a breakout in the other
end, okay? And that's what we've been
talking about. Why? Because you have
here some liquidity pools, okay? Check
out these imbalances, these large green
candles. They're probably going to get
retrace sooner or later, okay? Then you
have here this potential support
that we marked.
Okay, you can see here that that was
resistance, resistance, and this could
be a potential support zone that price
could hold or even deviate and get back
inside and then you can go long again
to the
range lows, 29,500, okay? That could be
a long setup if we get that. But, uh for
now I'm not going to look really into
that, okay? I'm just playing what the
market is giving me, and uh the shorting
short is still playing from here. I'm
only looking for a scalps and day trades
in this zone, okay? But, I'm still I'm
favoring this support wall, this um
level here
to get hit over the next Well, this week
or next week. Well, let's see what
happens. Um now, let's go into the
1-hour time frame. Let's try to
figure it out what's going on here. This
is very interesting because you got here
the weekend fake pump. Then, if we
notice
Asia dumped,
continued dumping, and then here London
carried on with dumping.
Now, what can we expect New York to do
today? Well, if I look at this,
the first thing that I notice is that,
you know, they're pushing price down
with aggressiveness. We are now below
the range lows. But,
this green candle here after this
aggressive move
is quite interesting, okay? And if we
check the volume of this green candle,
you can see that it almost has as much
volume as the red candle.
So, that means that here there is quite
a lot of
interest to push price back up, okay? Or
not continue going lower at least for
now.
So, in principle,
what I'm expecting is
I think uh well, this is a potential
liquidity pool here, too, because this
is a
$200 candle. So, we could see, you know,
Bitcoin recovering this green candle.
And then from here,
I think we could see a little push, to
be honest, okay? I think we could see a
little push here. I don't know if the
deviation case could happen, but I'm not
looking at that yet, okay? I think that
tomorrow, Tuesday, the market is going
to be boring, to be honest.
Usually, when we are 1 day away from
news announcements, the market prefers
to wait and hold and wait for the news.
So, that's what I'm expecting that, you
know,
this could happen. This is a needle that
could happen
over
um today. You could see maybe this green
candle recovering, then a push, and then
here on the resistance you could see
consolidation tomorrow. And then on
Wednesday,
if they announce another hike of 25
basis points, which I think they're
trying to price in now.
But if you got that plus
um Jerome Powell with a hawkish tone,
then that could bring price lower, okay?
If he for example says that yeah, we're
thinking about doing another interest
rate hike uh in the coming months,
then you know, Bitcoin is going to go
lower.
And of course the dollar index we're
going to go to the dollar index now.
It's going to bounce from here, okay? Uh
let me remove all of this.
All right, 4-hour time frame.
We've been talking about this idea. Let
me show you, okay?
Deviation below the level 100, cuz
that's very psychological if you go to
99, then recover that level. This bounce
from the dollar index is basically
because, you know, they're trying to
anticipate to the next FOMC meeting,
okay? To the next 25 basis points hike.
That's why it's pumping now. All right?
Now if you go to the 4-hour time frame,
you can see something interesting and is
that this candle from today, it tested
this level
as support.
Okay? So that could give you the idea
that the dollar index is probably set
for a continuation to the upside. Again,
it's likely that we might see the dollar
index holding here between today and
tomorrow. And then on Wednesday, 25
basis points and a hawkish Jerome
Powell, it could continue going higher.
Also, you have here another liquidity
pool, okay? 102
is dot 60. All right? So be mindful with
the dollar index. That's why I cannot be
really bullish on Bitcoin here. And I've
been
warning you that the most likely outcome
was Bitcoin
breaking to the downside of the range.
Also, another thing here I've just
noticed,
you got here
a gap in price
in the DXY.
This is going to get filled, okay?
That's at 100.20.
That gap is going to get filled at some
point, probably this week to be honest
with you. We're going to go now to
Hyblock Capital.
We're going to check out what's going on
with the liquidations. I think this is
just taking a very interesting turn. So,
let's go there. We're in Hyblock
Capital. Let's check out those
liquidation heat maps. In the 12-hour
time frame, I don't really see much
going on to be honest, so I'm going to
skip this one. Let's go to 47-day time
frame.
Okay, let's check this out.
Mhm,
not really much going on. Okay, I can
see that we were between two liquidation
zones, 31K
and
of course 29,300. And now, to be honest
there's still quite a lot of liquidity
at 28,800
and 28,700, okay? They might take this
liquidity later in the week, but what I
want to see is this 1-month time frame.
Check out this. Look what is going on
here.
You see all those liquidations here?
They've just hit them.
Um, these are basically
longs getting liquidated. It's a It's a
sad story, but this is how the market
works, okay? They're going to move price
in order to stop traders, to liquidate
traders, because that's money
for the market, okay? They are fees.
They are literally limit orders. They
get fees from them. Okay? So, that's why
the market is right to go to the stop
losses, and of course
to the liquidation level.
So, that's a sad story, but you can see
29,300, 29,200,
29,100.
Those liquidations have been hit. Now,
if we go let's get again the 1-month
time frame.
You can see in this chart that if you
notice what is the liquidity
well, it is still favoring lower prices.
Check out 24,300. But, if you go to the
3-month time frame, you can even see
this even clearer. Check this out.
Look at that.
Look at all those liquidations at
24,200.
So, this could tell you
a different story, okay? Of course, you
know, um we're going to go now into the
chart about what I can see here is that
first, we have to see if we can hold
here this this potential support at
28,400.
That's all That was also a range, if you
notice here.
And here we're going to go around to the
chart and I'm going to show you, but
if you If you lose this zone, 20,400,
we are probably going to go to the range
lows, which are around 25K, and that
leaves you pretty close, only 1K away
from this liquidation zone. So, um for
now, I'm going to favor a still lower
prices.
Um I'm going to take you now back to the
chart.
I'm going to basically do a little recap
of what I'm expecting price to do
between today and tomorrow, and also
Wednesday, and how we can trade this
price action.
Okay, so here I am now with me.
So, let me show you uh what I mean,
okay? I think that this was essentially
some kind of a range.
Let me mark it for you.
I believe that this was some kind of a
range.
Here you go. That's a range. Here you
got the deviation.
And then price, if you notice, breaks
out to the other end of the range.
Pretty much what is going on here.
You got a range here.
You got the deviation
above the range,
and then the breakout at the other end
of the range.
That's what I can see.
Pretty much the same, guys, but in the
opposite direction. Now,
if price takes
another drop
and goes to this support,
then here we got several scenarios,
okay? The first one would be
a deviation,
then get back inside this zone,
hold here, consolidate above support,
and that could be a long trigger. Again,
to this level over here, 29,500.
But, the other scenario is if you drop
here,
then consolidate on the resistance,
then
price is probably going to move lower
to the range lows and fall back inside
this range to 25,150.
But, then you have to worry about
because in this one here,
there is quite a lot of liquidations.
So, Bitcoin is not looking
the best at the moment. Again,
could this be a another deviation? Could
be. But,
guys, with the FOMC coming with a strong
dollar index, you just seen that they've
even tested that level as support. I
think the dollar is probably going to go
higher.
And Bitcoin is going to have a problem
with that. So, that's why I cannot
really be bullish in Bitcoin and
believing like in this case that this
was a deviation. Okay, I don't believe
that.
Could be. Again, I might be wrong with
this, but I don't you know, by looking
at the context,
I don't believe that this is going to
happen. Uh but, if it does, if it does,
then I want to see consolidation above
support here. And this would be another
long trigger to the mid-range. But,
again, I'm not seeing that very likely.
Instead, if I go to the 1-hour time
frame, what I can see is that
this green candle
is quite powerful, but it's also a
liquidity pool. So, I'm expecting price
to recover this green candle. Then from
here, we could see a bounce today. And
then, over tomorrow, maybe some
consolidation here on the resistance.
And then on Wednesday, with a new 25
basis point hike and a hawkish Jerome
Powell, they can set price lower. That's
what I think that's more likely to
happen at this point.
By the way, guys,
that's pretty much everything that I
wanted to say today. Also,
I'm thinking of doing a new uh altcoin
market update
because I saw some guys talking in the
Telegram yesterday
well two days ago sorry
I about the Bitcoin dominance about
where to buy the altcoins
I have an opinion okay I have an opinion
I might share it with you guys so I'm
thinking of making that video soon maybe
this week so anyway guys thank you so
much for watching
and I'll see you soon.